[Music]
this is definitely the biggest challenge
that ludwig has faced in
in either of his pog champs in either of
the podcamps that he's played in
um and i think we're to see how good his
nerves are because he's got to know
himself that he is the under
dog starters has been playing a lot more
than he has it's going to be very
exciting
yep it'll be interesting right because
we see sardosh has that hafu kind of
vibe grind right he came in
he's just been you know grinding for the
last month we know he's also been
working with kevin bourdee
blitzstream also gets a huge shout out
for for working with sardoche but
but then you have that experience factor
because because ludwig's been here since
pog one and we've been seeing him stream
chess for what the last
eight months now right and we know
that's gotta account for something
in regards to his experience so we'll i
wonder how that'll play out here between
the two of them
now we'll start i should go for the uh
the the double lift on the h file with
rook h4 and rook ddh1
i guess it's not actually lifts that's
just a double doubling up but will they
play rook h4 and rook d to h1 is uh
is actually quite a serious question
here right
well the only thing even stronger
potentially is something with g4 i mean
if he finds
and recognizes the idea to undermine the
knight and open this diagonal that would
be
that would be and i don't put it past
him he did play the grab for a while and
then he realized how bad that was
shout out to kevin bourdie good coaching
left that behind
but he does know of g4 right
that is true okay h6
logical stuff look at sarkozy 95
95 or g4 right away too
what a game by both these guys right now
i mean this is a this is a
this is pogchamps 3 presented by grip 6
everybody but this is some
quality chess here by by these two guys
i think that ludwig is in really bad
shape
um but again we'll see we'll see what he
does because he is deep and deep and he
is deep in thought right now
and the very close game on the clock
these two guys are
feeling the gravity the weight of the
situation
sardoche with a few good options
yeah many good options g4 f4 and knight
df3 are probably the three best moves
um in this position now if he sees the
idea of pushing the pawns forward to
open it up
then i understand he goes rook h3 which
i don't like
yeah i don't like rookie h3 at all here
um it to me it feels like sardosh is not
actually seeing the idea now
mind you f4 it's it's hard to play
because you hang g3 multiple ways
um but i think what he needs to realize
is that time matters here time really
does matter you have to
you have to be fast let's see what led's
about to do
i think i want to go f6
but how does he follow
oh he does go to absolutely i think
sardoche will see it now
pretty confident sorry for seeing 97. he
falls there
and ludwig saw it too right after he
played it he highlighted it and the
thing is i did see it too right
yeah okay
tough spot to be in for ludwig here but
it's not over actually in a way it's
good that he gives up the material
because now he's more chances to kind of
defend the position it's not so easy for
white to just attack anymore
i was just going to say that it's like
almost the accidental blunder because
that night
and and the potential sardocy already
had with opening up the position
is actually kind of going away now so
he's going to win the rook right
but this is this is not over i'm more
worried about ludwig being down a minute
on the clock than i am on the position
right now
right agreed yeah the position is
relatively okay here for um
for ludwig right but again
ludwig's plays knight before yeah a3982
when black is winning
a392 and then you stack a knight and you
get the fork oh my god what a
sick move i gotta show if a3 knight
a2 flip the script and drop a fork like
it's hot
keep it pg no thank you
right if you go to d1 it's the same
thing
exact same thing that is a nasty tactic
it's just shots wow
well you saw it instantly dude i
wouldn't see that if i had 10 minutes
there's a kingdom oh he played f3 blood
has it if he sees it
[Music]
although that's obviously that was super
hard but still
oh man i don't know but i don't think it
was hard danny because this pawn was
hanging for free it was a check it was
for free
so i actually don't think it was super
hard if you'd use time that's why it
started if sardosh goes a3 i understand
it being hard to find it but the fact
that it's a free pawn
and it's worth a check um i think he
should have he actually should have
found it but again both players are
getting low on time so it's not easy
it looks like he's backing up not that
bad though
[Music]
chief
yeah of course he sees it not surprising
because you don't just start really
sweating
queen e3 is a great move too
what a great game by these two guys
right here this is awesome to see the
championship racket come down to this
kind of chess
and there's only one good move for white
here which is rook to h1 otherwise black
is knight f6
or bishop to e2 collecting one of the
rooks here
well knight f6 93 but does ludwig see it
this is it this could be the
the win of game one if he sees knight f6
it's only one pawn
so it's still quite a ways to go but
yeah
oh oh no no no no no no no no no no no
he's gonna see it yeah
take your time don't move your king
surprise like he's working through
candidates
now he sees it yeah you're gonna see it
yeah he's gonna play it for sure
yeah wow awesome i like that he
worked through
what he did there everyone to learn from
it is he considered a movie didn't play
it
and he kept working through the position
and he eventually found knight f6
right and now you can see also when you
look at sardoche how
on edge he is um and again this is the
thing i would say to sardosh i feel like
when he doesn't have a clear-cut idea he
kind of he can get too nervous and bad
things can happen and um i mean he was
dominating this game
but ludwig again stayed in the game he's
hung around and sure he missed this
knight knight eight takes a2 idea but
overall
finding really good moves yep wow a5
okay uh-oh
okay now that was a pretty severe
mistake yeah by ludwig because now the
keys
he could he could have left the pawn
uh-oh we'll start don't see rook takes
e6
yeah this late game whoa
doesn't okay now ludwig's in the
driver's seat
yep carter's has to take with the d-pawn
he takes with the f pawn it's over but
he takes with a
pawn but now can love would find a move
like bishop b5
ooh king b6
i think this is still probably a draw
with correct play yeah
but wow what a game
and see the problem with this end game
is that it's um is that
it's a light square bishop that's the
problem the bishop can't touch any of
any of white's pawns yeah
bishop is just it's opposite colors now
king d6 and i think white is probably
winning
now can starters keep it together and go
king d6 is a big question if he goes
king d6 i think he's winning here
white could be up a night and still lose
the game to the corner pull up right oh
there's a f5 now though will starters go
f5
oh man f5 is winning you use the two the
two the two pawns go up the board
will he find it or not no he plays e6
first
that's not a bad move either yeah cause
ludwig probably won't take
wow this is crazy i think this is still
winning for white after bishop takes
pawn
but very hard to play now after king
takes pawn i think it should be winning
for sardosh look at his focus
blood hasn't talked in like three
minutes somebody somebody calls some
help
you know something's the best move um
what a move by sartosh 93 wow
that's impressive and now knight f5 and
you go the other way after the uh
pawn and h4 and i think there's almost
no chance that sardosh
misses it because the only piece you can
move here is the knife
yeah you're right yeah there's just no
way mrs knight of five amazing stuff
from
what technique there seriously you're
right
yep wow amazing stuff
that's probably better end game
technique than i've displayed in more
than a decade hikaru let's be honest
[Laughter]
yeah i mean star does really actually
i've said that his nerves have been his
biggest
biggest issue he's really kept it
together well in this game from the
winning position which i'm sure he knew
he had
to then when he was down a pawn in the
middle game to keep going uh very very
impressive
give up your c pawn and hope for
stalemate
nope but sardoche getting surgical up in
those dark squares thanks marcellus
wallace
fires in a blowtorch on g7 and we got
problems
this this is going to be an amazing
thing that was an amazing game
what a game
right and so we have the allopin um or
we have the the knight f6 variation
played here against the alpine cylinder
c3 sicilian
um gonna be very interesting to see what
happens i think your ludwig i don't know
if ludwig has looked at this
but i would hope that he's um that he's
looked at this a little bit at least
but i still think a6 is completely
reasonable too
but oh no not queen a4 no
super risky i think there are many
options that are good for for black here
i mean i think
bishop d7 is great
wow he just played it without even a
second thought what a move
wow and cers goes knight c7
i mean i don't even know what to say
he's just playing this like gm so far
he really is knight t7 was an all-star
move just because now you can put the
bishop on d5 and get a wooden shield
you also open up the diagonal as well
towards h1
yeah one risk of nice c7 though is if he
if he doesn't follow through with it and
let's say he he makes the mistake of
taking with the pawn
ludwig is cancelled ooh and see but
that's definitely not a good idea
that is definitely not a grand master
move
look how far we've come we're actually
criticizing them on the level of like
strong i mean in a good way
they're they're playing good shots that
is definitely not a grand master move
you highlighted it well though seriously
if you if he develops the knight and
puts the two brooks in the center
he's in a good shape right now the thing
is however i think for sardo she should
close the center with pawn to d5
and then try to develop the bushman
castle um
i think it's really important that he
tries to do that
yeah and a good reminder for you know we
know a big chess audience learning the
game is you almost never want to take a
piece that helps your opponent develop a
piece
almost never and bishop takes d2 did
just that so
hey queen c3 is also not bad but ludwig
can't okay you see she three
okay but you got it you gotta get going
over here on the queen side
well rook c1 and queen c6 is a huge
threat here so
um it's also on it's also on sardocher
he has to stop that he's playing rook c
if he does not play rook c8 white's
going to get rook c1
and he does wow okay so now we'll
playing knight b3 and get the bastion
huge moment yeah
rook c1 is not as good as it looks
because sardos can move the knight
and take care of everything but knight
b3 a8 only move by the way danny eight
is the only square because the e8 you
lose
ah so he'll be forced to find the corner
jump and then come to c4
so that's also why rook c1 is is not not
the best move
because knight f3 not a bad movie either
but not best because now i think i think
there's a good chance stardust will see
the idea of getting his knight to see
four with knight ap succeed
right the lord plays rook joint now the
question is will ludwig realize he's got
to take with a knight here because again
a draw is not good enough in this
position right he has to so i think
we'll realize that yeah he's got to take
with the knight because it's an end game
and a draw is not good enough here so
he's got to take with a knight and keep
the rook on the board
good move by ludwig two thumbs up again
it's now become
easier moves for low which is also
critical because he was running out of
time
c6 yeah i mean this is getting whoa this
is starting to turn around
this is starting to turn around
here he goes c6
this is starting to turn
big big moment here for ludwig that's
that's the mogu
i think he's going to make it magnus
proud someone clipped that
i think he's going to see rook h7
yeah i think he's gonna find rook h7
here wow
dude yep
better thinking faster playing
smarter
[Music]
smoke a cigarette frenchie you seem
stressed out
it's just a chess game about
relax thousands happened in the time
we've been playing
wow sardoce is i mean i think ludwig
could win this game
he totally can win this game and the
other reason that i think he can win is
because again the only i
only routing of the knight that that
works here is c7
8 b64 it's again a very unusual pathing
of the night and i just
i don't whoa maybe he sees it though he
found the first move
he found knight c7
okay this is i mean again it yeah
does he see this or was it was this sort
of just the lucky
lucky square that he picked i think it
might just be a lucky square that he
picked
yeah i think you're yeah it's just so
ran it's just so weird
moving you're moving your knight to the
corner it's just it's a weird concept
that
i mean the pathing is just so strange
yep and and
the fact that it's so tricky is is going
to make it
easier for you you know you're totally
right
but ludwig's going the wrong way with
the king he needs to go to the kings now
he's figured it out
yeah now he's got it yep and here we go
king comes into f6 and he's gonna
get this thing i think ludwig's gonna
win yeah because now he's gonna see
knight f8 next move what a brilliant
game
what a brilliant recovery by ludwig it
actually you know it feels like
in the end games ludwig has been a
little bit better than than sardosh it's
just
the critical moments um in that first
game just like one or two little minor
mistakes
shifted it but like in this game he's
just outplayed sardosh in this whole end
game
and now knight f8 oh wow what am i
looking at the game right now
from ludwig and he's going to win he's
going to win wow
wake up boys and girls we're headed down
to a tiebreaker yeah it's a tiebreaker
yep wow man all in sick
drink your favorite your vermont day
wait can i say it like that don't miss
again that's right
[Music]
wow and first design
i always lose the first i always lose
the first
did you just do a trump impersonation oh
my god we don't want to talk about that
you said i always lose them
wow that was weird oh my gosh
by the way i love this opening i think
this is actually in a blitz game very
beneficial for white i think it was much
more advantageous
um because i think i think it's unless
you know exactly how to develop with
black
um i i think that uh in general it's
it's really um it's it's really hard to
play you'll have to use a lot of time
figuring out how to develop your piece
now let's remember
this is no longer a draw odds for for
black which between
these two guys might have mattered
because sardosh might be able so this is
good good for ludwig shout out to ezra's
monkey you also love your username
yeah exactly so let's see what happens
here okay
queen d2 threatens bishop h6 if black
gets castle so this is advantage ludwig
in the opening
gardosh feeling the pressure yeah
definitely i think here for sardoche
um he takes on e5 very scary move now
knight takes pawn is playable pawn takes
pawn
i think there might be an f6 trick here
oh yeah that would but
i think it's very scary to play i think
it's very scary to go f6 here
light takes i think f6 is probably good
for black but very scary to play
see what happens
oh he finds f6 okay amazing
he takes right away yeah
bishop h6 is probably the best move here
but tough move to play
[Music]
he's up one minute on the clock
it's still very much a game knight c3 is
a good no don't take it ludwig don't
panic
oh no he's panicking
he's had such good whoa nerves
that work or not quick yes because he
has bishop e6
wow even if one of them
oh wow almost a huge blunder by sargosh
this might have been yeah i mean what
happened
knight d5 though not knight d5 okay okay
it's not over this is crazy it's not so
great
you're already
[Music]
this is insane like ludwig totally
panicked and lost his mind there
7 by sardosh what a move
great move by sardosh
it's like when he doesn't have time to
think he's actually playing better yeah
he's playing like much better than when
he had time to think
yep pretty amazing this very there's
almost
nothing i can say negative about this
game sort of just played an amazing game
yeah seriously the fact that he found
f6 2 was huge i mean he blood was all in
when he knew he was better
and up on time but it's one of those
tricky moments he kind of got a little
unlucky with knight takes e5 but still
it's it's really hard to know that
you don't have to start sacrificing you
know right yeah
yeah and now the moves play themselves
bishop c5 check and rook h1 is
beat yeah
ouch oh the fork yeah i mean basically
the reason that i would say
i mean ludwig lost this game is because
he panicked he just he panicked in the
middle there for a couple of
for a couple of moves that was really
the difference um
in general yeah there's sardosh i've
seen him mate with king and rook he just
he knows how to mate
there's just no way i mean that temple
with the rook wasn't even necessary he
delivers it wow
yeah i know i mean i saw that coming
yeah yeah yeah
yeah we saw it in his match against nico
that's one thing that i noticed even in
pog 2
the people who um the people who had
that technique where they could ignore
half the board whether like a king of
rook or a king and a queen um
those those were the guys who were very
very dangerous and you could tell very
early on that sargon
you can see how much this means to him
just crazy
blood here's the thing dude like a
badass mogul moves everywhere
i know this didn't end how you wanted
but man i mean
i feel money i actually like when i lost
to charlie no cap and consolation i was
like
crushed i was like sad i wanted to win
but i i realized because i started
coaching with hess
way before this tournament was announced
before i knew about it
uh all i've wanted to do is just get
better at chess and i think
much like logic felt after losing it i
just feel good like i'm i'm
cracked now bro like i i took a game off
sardosh dude
you saw everything i was planning to do
you always come to play it
uh you missed some blunder as i did
obviously but well yeah i was i was
i was in more difficulty than in my uh
1400 games actually
i was impressed at your speed because
usually i'm pretty up on time control in
my games
and i definitely had to tank for like
half my moves
because uh because you had like bro you
you playing like a true frenchie dude i
can't get it i
i knew you would actually try to flag me
so i will never let the clock
uh yeah get for for your favor uh
i would play a move even though it
wasn't the best but
uh it was important for me to to put a
pressure on you so you could actually
blender so
yeah yeah it definitely worked because i
think game one i i definitely had a lead
i knew that after i took the rook
with the night fork and then i was lower
on the clock in my end game
you know i'm sad to say i lost to
vorsky's endgame manual on the move
and uh yeah that hurts you're really
good at the game actually i
i didn't train that enough i didn't win
enough into terry
you can't say i'm good when you beat me
in it that's not how it works but guys
i mean you guys you guys seriously
played fantastic chess and hikaru and i
were
i mean i i said before we went to right
here
no but i mean you know i think to be to
be clear i mean i think actually yeah
like
ludwig i mean sardosh is not wrong i
thought in the end games you played
really really well like that second game
especially when you were down the pawn
and at the start
with the rooks in the night you played
that extremely well just the whole way
moving the rook and taking the pawn on
one side and bringing the rook back to
the other side to grab the other pawn
and bringing the king in
i mean i i couldn't have done it better
myself so i i think you're selling
yourself a little bit short because that
end game was was amazing
we said on camera mud right here we said
he said if blood finds rook a7
called magnus because we got some mogul
moves going and you played it and rookie
this was literally
brand master level end game technique i
believe you not
[Music]
you